[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the Easter eggs and other
references you might have missed while
watching the first the Super Mario
Brothers movie trailer if you liked the
video be sure to leave us a like And
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite animation movies without
further Ado let's get started
the film begins with Bowser and his
Armed Force clashing with a gang of
courageous but defenseless penguins in
the enigmatic ice kingdom this is one of
the trailer's most interesting
developments as the Penguins call this
Kingdom home the Penguin's
configurations are influenced by the
penguins from Super Mario 64. more
particularly the notorious quest in
which Mario must recover a mother
penguin's baby for her in a swap for a
star it's particularly notorious because
directly following your gutsy relief
efforts you could really take the baby
back and plunger down a Mountainside
imagine the audience's loud cheers and
shrieks if that incident is reinvented
for the motion picture
before we get our first formal peek at
the motion picture Mario's facial
features Mario trips and falls on a
mushroom prior to actually Wheeling onto
the garden for a short instant when he
first shows up in the Mushroom Kingdom a
yellow butterfly seemed to appear in the
picture whilst Mario is resting there
briefly obscuring the view of his face
in addition to being a stunning Scene It
appears to be a fitting tribute to the
closure of Super Mario Galaxy it's not
precisely a that but it is an amazing
possibility when we cut to a field of
view of Mario trying to stand up we
could see a cluster of butterflies all
around him if Mario is still he has seen
to attract and retain butterflies just
as in Super Mario 64. not to point out
the numerous butterflies observed
throughout the trailer which contribute
to making the Mushroom Kingdom resemble
the entire area out Beyond Peach's
Palace in Super Mario 64.
the weight seems to be over and we can
finally hear Jack Black's Bowser voice
in the trailer and what a wonderful
representation it is nearly every single
character in this teaser has had their
voices modified but Jack Black seems to
be hammering Bowser in this also how
about we just say that many of the
characters here have been significantly
altered for the motion picture but it
just seems that they attempted
tirelessly to make Bowser look similar
to Jack Black provided that he's the
central protagonist of the teaser it's
no shock that Bowser is the biggest
feature of the very first appearance of
the motion picture which is a
collaborative effort between Nintendo
and illumination it begins with his
absolutely fantastic aerial lava Castle
threateningly bobbing towards that ice
kingdom before ridiculing a few stupid
penguins and then burning their Kingdom
to the ground it's suitably fearsome and
utterly stupid but the real icing on the
cake is Jack Black's audio effort
given that this is an animated feature
film The teaser served more as a first
here than a first look at renowned
actors who play some of the world's
largest and most well-known characters
from video games Chris Pratt who gets to
play Mario does not speak with an
Italian accent it's difficult to forget
about in fact the guardian of the galaxy
star does not have much of a dialect
just an indication of New York finesse
if you look at the trailer once more
you'll start noticing that it's
primarily Pratt attempting to speak in
his normal tone keep in mind how he said
that it would be unlike anything we had
ever got to hear previously perhaps it
was specifically speaking to the
individuals of the Mushroom Kingdom
because Mario certainly appears to be
unfamiliar there in the film's spiritual
Realm
we can see what does seem to be Bowser's
aerial vehicle at around 25 seconds into
the trailer despite the fact that it is
not a perfect replica of the Mario game
Bowser's Castle seems to click just as
rapidly it shares numerous systemic
resemblances such as the quick release
chain system this seems to be a whole
Bowser threshold in which Bowser can
take flight and commute he seems to be
commuting with his invading Squad and he
obviously necessitates a massive aerial
Island to better accommodate them all
Mario is presently able to properly take
a break not only is he getting voiced by
Chris Pratt who sounds almost exactly
like Chris Pratt but he's also had his
greatest feature his bum nerfed in the
forthcoming Super Mario Brothers motion
picture that's completely right
followers have specifically noted that
the Plumber's derriere is much thinner
than regular and now even as former
adversary is taking shots at him Sonic
has decided to make fun of Mario's butt
in a narrative that starts to feel
directly out of the 1990s after the
release of the Super Mario movie teaser
the Sonic movie account posted on
Twitter that he couldn't match up to the
insults hurled at his Rivals outward
appearance even stronger he mentioned
specifically Mario's lure body layout
criticizing his behind as not being good
enough as a direct consequence United
supporters on both ends are trying to
debate whether Mario's ass is sufficient
enough for the motion picture this is
obviously a jibe at Sonic's original
movie layout while unfortunate looking
Sonic is already better known for his
odd looking face genuine supporters
might very well recollect that it was as
low lower half precisely his legs that
first perceive criticism Sonic's legs
were oddly redefined and most
disturbingly were human in the initial
posters so although it wasn't his bum
Sonic could completely relate to the
lower portion of his body becoming a
source of contention all in all it is a
very interesting debate
around 29 seconds further into the
teaser we encounter Kevin Michael
Richardson as kamek kamek normally comes
to add his morally corrupt magical charm
to the stage in order to make things
more challenging for Mario but in the
opening number he seems to be Bowser's
best man for the job if you look very
closely you will notice that the
particulate outcomes of kamex
telekinesis are the same as the ones he
utilizes when casting magic spells in
the video game Kevin Michael Richardson
has indeed been lending his voice to
fully animated initiatives for years but
playing the mischievous kamek will be
among his greatest and most prominent
roles
when a Mario without an Italian accent
shows up in the Mushroom Kingdom he is
alarmed and then warmly welcomed by toad
when the protagonist of the motion
picture tries to reach out to make
contact with a blue mushroom toad starts
screaming at him trying to warn him that
it is highly toxic the warning is
adequate as relying on the light sources
it could be mistaken for the legendary
poison mushrooms which are distinctively
magenta with pink patches toad then
starts laughing having realized he has
committed an error this could be a
specific reference to the toxic
mushrooms that have shown up in
preceding Mario games toad may have
mistakenly taken the blue and white one
Mario appears to be trying to reach for
the toxic kind because it is magenta
with pink spots but even so blue and
white wild mushrooms are reported to
scale down Mario making them something
to be extremely cautious of
a segment of Cannon fires can be seen in
the central portion of the Koopa Army in
a wider angle if you've ever got to play
a Mario video game particularly Super
Mario Brothers 3 you'll know precisely
how much Koopas love and adore cannons
there's a good combination of Koopas
from various and Sundry Mario games as
well as a few with Bowser flags and
Banners long and quadrilateral with a
skeletal Bowser's face right on the
middle of them they have now become
culturally significant in the Mario
spiritual realm due to their usage since
the start of the series in the initial
games gold Towers were most usually
associated with Mario trying to jump on
them and trying to replace the Bowser
Banner with his own clearly showing the
level was accomplished
when searching for secret information in
the Mushroom Kingdom the very first
thing you'll come across is the cheap
Jeeps swimming in the riverbank they'll
require a magnifying glass to see but
they're certainly there anyway they are
puffer fish which first showed up in
Super Mario Brothers in the underground
stages they are commonly occurring
adversaries all throughout the Mario
video game franchise they are most often
encountered in the water but they can
swoop out of it as well as shown in
Mario Super Sluggers cheap Jeeps come at
a wide range of colors and are found in
numerous different versions of Super
Mario video games cheap Jeeps can Target
just above the surface of the liquid by
trying to jump out in an action sequence
the majority of cheap Jeeps appear to be
connected with Bowser and the Koopa
troop whereas others such as those shown
in Super Paper Mario choose not to
a star can also be seen in the trailer
in the Mario spiritual realm Stars can
portray a wide range of things they
every once in a while but still
momentary omnipotence in games like
Mario 64 and Mario Galaxy they are
occasionally the major element that
Mario seeks to control other times they
are the element that decides who ends up
winning a game of Mario Party
nevertheless they have always been
highly coveted after and it just seems
that Bowser's primary objective is to
collect and store them one has to make
the assumption that there is more than
just one star in the motion picture and
that there is almost certainly one
tucked away somewhere within the
Mushroom Kingdom which is what will
eventually bring Mario and Bowser to
team up
that's it for now have you noticed some
of these references already did we leave
out another Easter egg or reference let
us know in the comments down below be
sure to leave us a like if you enjoyed
the video and subscribe for more content
on the biggest upcoming Blockbusters
until next time
[Music]